hey it's me again we're going to talk
about hair loss okay so there's a
question from a lady that said I'm
losing my hair and I need some help so
we're going to answer what causes that
when you're dealing with hair loss you
have to make sure that you don't treat
the symptom which is hair loss and
that's like directly because you have to
find the cause of it and hair loss is a
symptom so people are taking biotin in
the doing shampoos with all these
collagen and things and vitamins
thinking that's going to absorb in the
hair and do something it's it's a joke
it's not going to happen like that so in
my book I talk about in two different
sections because there's really three
different situations going on with hair
one is actually in Chapter 7 on the
thyroid body type so the thyroid gland
can cause thinning of the hair thinning
brittle hair okay that would be thyroid
but again what causes the thyroid
problem that's what you need to dig in
there I always like to use a question
when did it start
that gives the clue what what happened
just before it started did you get
pregnant and then you lost your hair did
you start a diet and start losing your
hair for example I had someone
completely almost bald and it was after
she did a high protein diet and all that
protein was the wrong thing for her body
type and that aggravated her liver you
have to have a good liver to digest all
that protein well anyway one of the
causes of thyroid is a liver problem it
blocked the liver boom the thyroid can't
convert to the liver and she lost all
her hair now I've had other people do a
vegetarian diet after watching the
documentary called it's called forks
over knives summit forks over knives I
think it is where they talk about being
a vegetarian well they cut out all
protein in lost all their hair so and
they started breaking down their teeth
so really you want to adjust the
eating plan to your body type not just
do like you can't do a one-size-fits-all
but the point is that what can cause a
thyroid problem usually is a liver
problem or a lack of bile that detergent
that does some that helps you break down
the grease from your gall bladder and if
you're missing a gall bladder or you get
bloating or you have constipation or you
have a liver problem that alone can
block the thyroid and cause a thinning
so do you want to work on the thyroid
know you want to support liver again ask
yourself when did it start what happened
just before now we have estrogen spike
estrogen can also block the thyroid from
a pregnancy being on HRT hormone
replacement therapy birth control pills
consuming lots of soy all those things
can spike estrogen and block your
thyroid okay so how do you know if you
have is trojan watch my video on high
oestrogen
the symptoms are heavy period a problem
with your cycle heavy weight on the
lower part of your body fibroids that
that would all indicate that you have
too much estrogen so these two two
things can block the thyroid and cause
thing of your hair so that's one cause
the next thing we're talking about is
receding hair or male pattern baldness
now that is a androgen problem what is
androgens that's a male hormone it's a
type of testosterone and women have it
too and so when that hormone goes higher
what happens is it starts to burn out
the hair follicles and it starts to
recede or you start losing hair on the
top part right here
men and women now if this happens if
you're getting receding hair there's
three causes to that one is high levels
of insulin okay and that comes from
sugar or refined carbs now excess
insulin can convert estrogen into
androgens and that's why women that have
polycystic ovarian syndrome PCOS there
they get put them on metformin
to say what's called insulin resistance
well that's because their their insulin
has been too high and causing us some
resistance and triggering this effect so
again this could cause that alright high
levels of cortisol that's stress what
can that do well think about it the
adrenal gland makes three hormones on
the outside of the adrenal bag cortisol
which is a stress hormone androgens and
in another hormone called aldosterone
but we're going to talk about if this
adrenal band is over working like in
sustained stress it will raise all three
of these hormones and so you're going to
high energies just from an overactive
adrenal and that will cause the
receiving hair and a lot of times it'll
cause facial hair so the hair goes from
here to here or it's going to you're
going to get acne okay so increase
insulin cortisol or this other hormone
called igf-1 like growth factor I don't
want to confuse you but let me just kind
of give you the summary of what what
this is this is a hormone from your
liver and you make it you make all three
of these but a lot of times when you
consume the wrong foods specifically soy
protein isolates and diet foods that
will spike the IGF and create high
levels of androgen - so in other words
it's back to the liver again if
something aggravates your liver you can
actually have high androgens and have
receiving error so again we got to look
at the different things that it could be
going to be thyroid never so as you can
see so far we got a lot of liver
situations going on okay but then this
last one you can have patches of your
hair come out in different places that's
called alopecia
that's an autoimmune problem where your
body is attacking your own hair root so
it's like an allergy to your own hair
now that usually comes from an
overactive adrenal from a stress event
so we're back to stress again so most
stress events will cause autoimmune and
that's why a lot of autoimmune
conditions whether it's rheumatory
arthritis
as alopecia whatever comes after a loss
of a loved one or maybe some type of
accident or an injury or sustained
stress so if we really want to know the
cause of stress it's a combination of
stress sugar eating the wrong things
so I protein isolates the liver or
having too much estrogen in the diet in
the environment or just having your body
pump out too much because you're you
have a fibroid so I have specific videos
and all these I just wanted to give you
a summary on the general possible causes
of hair loss I hope this helps so if you
want just watch some of these specific
videos through my blog and see if you
can find out now what to do about it
alright so this is dr. Burke signing off
and I'll see you in the next video